[Music]
franki grande gushes over little sister
Ariana's engagement to Pete Davidson
it's a time to celebrate et caught up
with the 35 year old singer on Monday
ahead of his performance at the Broadway
sings for pride annual charity concert
in New York City oh my I mean I'm so
happy for my sister for my whole family
it's a big year for her sweetners coming
very excited the light is coming is
coming out in like minutes which are
very unbelievably excited about there's
an interlude called Pete on the album
yes I've heard the whole thing it's it's
truly remarkable it's a remarkable piece
of work just as a family were in a
really good place it's a time to
celebrate it's joy it's happiness it's
it's it's kind of just
it's the grande's year and that's all
I'm gonna say you know oh God look out
for us everywhere Frankie also got
candid about his big milestone
celebrating one year of sobriety the
support is be incredible what happened
was I was very silent for a long time I
was afraid to ask for help I was afraid
to be vulnerable is afraid to show
people that I was broken so I just kind
of created this facade of everything is
great everything is shiny and beautiful
and glittery but now actually is shiny
and beautiful and buttery but on the
inside and I asked for help I got help
and I'm here today because of it yeah
it's amazing and opened up about what
the Broadway sings for pride charity
means to him pride means never having to
apologize for who you actually are it's
an amazing tour closets with Tyler
Clementi foundation and they're trying
to help end online and offline bullying
which I feel like is the stem of so many
problems a lot of like drug abuse and
alcohol abuse stems from being bullied
when you were a kid and like let's stop
that earlier I just celebrated my one
year of sobriety and it's been such a
beautiful journey and I don't know I
just wish I had more people looking
for me like way early on like in that
kind of way
[Music]